We had some questions about toxicity sources when we go and take CT scans at MRI images.
And is that a source of toxicity that we should be concerned about?
Now, the problem with CT scans is you have a lot of radiation.
The nominal CT study is equivalent to about 50 x-rays equivalent rad radiation.
And of course, that's a lot of radiation.
And what does radiation do with our body?
Because cancer.
So radiation damages cell membranes and damages the nucleus and could cause the cell to go into rapid replication.
That's why people that are exposed to radiation get cancer.
So what are we doing when we're going to getting CT scans every three months?
Well, that's not maybe a good idea.
So then the option is can I use a MRI image?
Well, the MRI image, most of them you have to use a contrast.
Many of the CT scans they're using a contrast too.
So there's problems with those things.
And I have said to you, if you said, well, how am I supposed to know I'm getting better?
So the CT scan showed a 2.6 millimeter mass in my liver.
How do I know if I'm getting better?
I don't feel anything.
Well, then again, you have to compare apples to apples if you want to know objectively that you're getting better.
So you're going to have to do another CT scan.
Is that the best thing to do?
That's a decision you're going to have to make.
Do you have to know those things?
That's what's exciting about the IVG test coming out.
Because we're going to have some quantitative data that we could look at and we could measure over time.
And it's going to be completely not invasive.
It's just a blood draw.
So these are invasive tests that you've heard me say that, you know, to do an invasive test,
you only do an invasive test if it's going to change the way you treat the patients.
That's what I always used to tell doctors that I taught.
I really do an invasive test if it's going to change the way you treat the patient.
So the question that I ask you usually is that, oh, well, you want to do a CT scan.
Should I do a CT scan?
Well, if you did a CT scan, then you found out the cancer was worse.
Would you do chemo?
Would you change your treatment protocol?
That's what I'm asking.
If the answer is, yeah, I might.
Well, then you better do the CT scan because if you're looking for that qualitative data,
then you have to compare apples with apples and you have to do the test.
And then you have to deal with the contrast and you have to deal with the radiation.
We're going to get to a second how you could deal with those things in just a second.
But these are some of the different types of contrasts that you get with CT scans.
And this is some of the symptoms that you could get with the contrast.
You could have an allergic sensitivity to it.
And the biggest thing is a toxic sensitivity to it.
You're just exposed to a toxin that now has detoxify out of your body.
This is actually a slide taken to teach doctors about radiation exposure after CT scan and IV contrast reactions.
And this is an antiflactic reaction pretty nasty looking.
That's pretty uncommon.
And that's not really what I'm really concerned with any type of an allergic reaction to an IV.
I'm talking about what is it doing to a person's liver.
So your body has to detoxify that not to mention the radiation.